hallo deutsch schule deutsch lernen mit
spaß
[Musik]
es ist ein sehr guter schüler
die preise auch sehr günstig ich finde
die schüler sehr freundlich kleine seit
sieben monaten an der schule deutsch
es gefällt mir sehr die post ist eher
günstig aber nicht nur günstig sondern
auch sehr viele käufer es hat und
zweiter ist sehr nach und der cd kommt
bahnhof es dauert nur zehn oder 15
minuten mit dem rad oder zu fuß kommen
nur was
und trotzdem wir ziehen
nicht
das ist ihnen eine kleine gruppe
haben nicht mehr als zu legen zusammen
er habe nicht
und ich denke dass es gibt viele sehr
gute materialien in ihre website und ich
denke dass alles sehr gut gemacht in
dieser sprechen die anbietet und die
atmosphäre ist sehr selten
und ich habe so viele freunde gemacht ja
das ist viel und wir lernen mit viel
spaß das war für mich ja ich denke
gleich die atmosphäre und die stimme ist
es sehr gut
spannend und lustig wenn sie fliegen und
fliegen mit dieser schule
ja ja ja aber das ist ja alles ist cool
es sehr gut
[Musik]
mit mir aus aber ich genese entwickler
sie sind interessant auch wir machen
und dann
[Musik]
im umgang mit essen
es ist immer interessant finde
hallo deutschkurse design größer du
kannst du ganz lernen wie schnell du
ganz wanderwitz immer die alte schule
ist aus
die buche ist super ich empfehle diese
schule für alle
[Musik]
[Applaus]